in my classroom i always ask them who  are you they know to respond i am the  leader of the world and it's true  they're the future  the importance of teachers is done  quantifiable for the success of students  because we do  not just teach but we really care about  our students  we're also their mentors we're also  their friends  every teacher uses different tools to be  an effective teacher one of those tools  that i choose to use because i believe  the curriculum the rigor in it is khan  academy so it gives me immediate  feedback of okay this person understands  or this person doesn't every student  every child every life has the  possibility to create something everyone  deserves access to free quality  education then we can really see the  power of education blossom  [Music]